but in many ways putin has already lost
far from being the far-sighted
manipulator of events that he would have
us believe
putin has damaged himself through a
series of catastrophic misjudgments
he has failed to recognize how deeply
the notions of sovereignty democracy and
national identity have taken root in
ukraine
like all authoritarians he allowed
himself to be misled as to his own
strength
including the effectiveness of the
russian armed forces
and lastly he has failed to anticipate
the unity and cohesion that exists among
the free nations of the world
here in europe and obviously far beyond
his actions to date have done more to
galvanize than divide and have shown
ukraine to have the one thing that
russia conspicuously lacks which is real
friends
uh well let's speak to our deputy
political editor sam coats today uh
because what quite a lot is being said
about vladimir putin's judgment by some
very senior figures you've just come um
from that meeting sam what else did he
have to say
uh well sir tony radican uh appeared at
the institute for government with a
series of warnings and assessments about
where we are he is a very senior figure
in the british government he advised the
cabinet this week uh on the question of
whether or not more arms should be sent
to ukraine what type of arms uh should
be sent to ukraine he told the chief of
government event that that was
constantly under review as britain looks
uh whether or not we can flex and expand
the definition of defensive missiles uh
and send useful uh materials to ukraine
but the most striking part of the event
was however he described the situation
on the ground
in ukraine uh the chief of the defense
staff said we're starting to see the
early indications of russian forces
being moved back from around kiev
and into russia and belarus he said that
this would be a difficult retreat for
president putin they are doing this
because they are under fire from
ukrainian forces uh the point that he
was trying to get across however was
that uh britain does not take at face
value necessarily statements by russia
that they are no longer trying to take
uh trying to take keeve as a primary
objective in this war he reminded
everybody in the room that russia
declared at the start it had no
intention of going in uh to ukraine to
try and take the country that proved
false so you can only monitor what is
happening on the ground rather than take
the pronouncements of the russian
government
he flinched a little at suggestions that
there was an outright mutiny around
people
around people who surround president
peter and he suggested that was a rather
strong term instead he suggested that
what uh intelligence was picking up was
signs
of just unhappiness clearly some of the
advice being given to putin hasn't
turned out to be right he's not sure
whether it goes all the way through to
outright mutiny
but he said that clearly there is
unhappiness uh there
but the picture that he was presenting
of where president putin
is at the moment in this conflict was
bleak making clear that putin is not
achieving his strategic strategic
objectives even though the conflict
could have some weeks left to go